el beisbolista jackie robinson
o el geógrafo georges anglade
son solo algunos ejemplos de
personalidades propuestas a la comisión
toponimia de quebec
es ante todo subrayar su
contribución
lo que muchas veces no se dice
que Quebec desde el principio así que desde su
fundación ya era plural el editor
de la revista 35 quantum explica que
es parte de la raíz y yo
permite que la gente se diga a sí misma aquí está
en casa ya que hay gente que
parece
primero y cuando vengas eso
estaba bien cuando vas a nueva york
encontrarte cuando vayas guiado
encontrar fácilmente el bulevar
martin luther king le boulevard malcom x
de todo eso que esa liga mas o menos asi
es una apropiación para la vida nosotros
nos dicen si nuestras raíces están aquí
hay algunas comunidades que
más interesado en esto
situación la manzana los italianos otros
que fueron capaces de encontrar en unos pocos
barrios que podrían arrastrar
algunos nombres pero sobre todo eso
seguir siendo totalmente canadiense de nuevo
francés
la comisión a lo largo de los años alcanzada y
salida, queríamos asegurarnos especialmente
que toponimia son los hierros franceses
preservado y luego evoluciona
evolucionó con los cambios en el
sociedad
portavoz de la comisión
toponimia de quebec jean-pierre leblanc
se defiende bien dice que quiere hacer una
más espacio para los negros pero también
a los aborígenes y a las mujeres y que
llevará más tiempo
es un trabajo a largo plazo
hace cada año el hecho de ser
consciente del trabajo a realizar
que estos grupos sean reconocidos en el
toponimia la toponimia es un poco
el reflejo de nuestra historia es un
el trabajo que es bastante lento se hace
no, no queremos hacerlo
de repente los eu nuncios serán
no todos se reemplazan al mismo tiempo, por lo que
quiero ir lento y
ataque pasivo obtener un consenso pero
la comisión de toponimia de québec
puede moverse rápidamente cuando el
la presión aumenta y alcanza un cierto
nivel
por ejemplo las palabras negro enegel en
todo estaba prohibido de la toponimia
Quebecer tuvo recientemente en 2015 en
tras una denuncia de un
representantes de la comunidad negra
un caso que había causado revuelo
nieve no acepto ver tal
término en signos que hace en quebec
pagado por el gobierno había
peyorativo camuflado y el negativo
todos estamos de acuerdo en que esto
término no debería tener lugar
aquí en quebec
Creo que hicieron una parada.
nuestra historia podemos valorar nuestra
historia sin usar nombres que son
pintoresco
buenas noches a veces saben lo mejor
las intenciones no necesariamente dan
los mejores resultados con el tiempo
en outaouais, un curso de agua lleva el nombre
recuerda a los negros imaginando que parece
que conmemorar la memoria
de dos personas a 45 años después una
nombre que levanta las cejas es el
menos podemos decir que es un nombre que
retrocede un largo camino y luego uh no, yo
no tome en el verdadero sentido de la palabra si
eso es lo que quieres saber quien
quédate o vete rápido tú
permanecer la operación debe saludar el hecho
que pensaron hacerlo bien con
varios en plomo hechos pero hoy
en 2015
la palabra negro en el nombre de un río
su puerta casi pone un todo
comunidad
y tal vez cambie el nombre para que sas
podría reconciliar a los dos
comisión de toponimia de québec en la
banco que se sepa que este nombre estaba en
usado por generaciones
parte de la historia del lugar y que
cortarlo fue un año sin sentido
plan histórico la comisión de
toponymie du québec también invocó la
hecho para no actuar tantos
los negros en quebec lo tenían
significaba que ella no deseaba
cambiar no somos negros somos
descendiente de un esclavo nosotros también entonces
no puedo encontrar eso no no
para nada insultante no me molesta
no este año no puedes no puedes
cambiar el color de la piel
alguien
unas semanas después el
la comisión de toponimia estaba trabajando
atrás y ahí están los once nombres
retirado por la comisión de toponimia
de quebec últimos lugares en canadá donde
estas palabras aún estaban presentes en el
ponga su nombre
por qué tal retraso es también un
tal prevalencia de sus usos intenta
responder a estas preguntas levantaría la
navegando con cierta temeridad pero
también dicen del sentido del humor
típico de los quebequenses el fotógrafo
historiadores de quebec pierre lahoud
se da cuenta de que la imaginación bastante
millones abrumados
varios otros lugares en la puerta de Quebec
todavía hoy pocos nombres
políticamente sigue siendo un tiro divertido
incluso ofensivo está por ejemplo el
estrecho de nalgas apretadas
así como la calle de la paja en santo
jeans vistiendo bastante
se dice que el lugar fue una antigua
zona pantanosa y sólo para consolidar
la carretera
le habíamos puesto bios de madera, así que
cuando la gente pasaba decíamos
que luego se hicieron la paja
un informe de radio canada
internacional